nosotros ya sabemos que si tenemos dos
triángulos
en donde todos sus lados
correspondientes tienen la misma
longitud es decir que tienen sus tres
lados lado lado lado iguales esto
implica que el triángulo o que los
triángulos van a ser congruentes
congruentes
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar si existen otras propiedades
entre triángulos que nos ayuden a
demostrar que los triángulos son
congruentes
así que lado lado lado ya sabemos que
funciona bueno qué tal funcionaría
ángulo ángulo ángulo
ángulo ángulo ángulo este no funcionaría
imaginemos que tenemos un triángulo como
este así más o menos
un lado
otro lado
y otro lado y tenemos además otro
triángulo hacia un lado
otro lado
otro lado más o menos así
y si sabemos que este ángulo es
congruente con este otro ángulo
este ángulo de acá es congruente con
este otro ángulo de acá y además sabemos
que este ángulo de aquí también es
congruente con este ángulo de acá
podremos decir que ambos triángulos son
congruentes
la vista parece que si se cumple pero
cuando tenemos ángulos correspondientes
iguales en dos triángulos podríamos
escalar uno de ellos haciéndolo quizás
más grande por ejemplo yo puedo hacer
este triángulo así
y así
de los ángulos internos este ángulo de
acá es correspondiente con este ángulo
de acá donde también este ángulo de aquí
es igual a estos otros dos ángulos y
también el ángulo de arriba este de acá
sea también congruente con estos dos
pero este triángulo de acá no es
congruente con los otros dos porque es
más grande el tamaño de sus lados no es
el mismo que el de estos dos
todos los lados de este último triángulo
son mucho más grandes que los
correspondientes a estos dos así que el
ángulo ángulo ángulo no nos sirve
esto no nos sirve para la congruencia
prudencia no os podría servir para decir
que son triángulos similares que tienen
los mismos ángulos pero el tamaño puede
ser diferente este sí nos podría servir
para la similitud
y litus pero no para la congruencia
la palabra similar tiene un significado
bastante específico en geometría las
cosas similares tienen la misma forma
pero no necesariamente el mismo tamaño
así que cualquier cosa que es congruente
ya que tiene la misma forma y tamaño
también será similar pero no cualquier
cosa que sea similar será congruente
también estos tres triángulos son
similares entre sí pero solo estos dos
son congruentes y sus lados
correspondientes se miden lo mismo
es decir que esté este lado tiene mide
lo mismo que este lado este lado mide lo
mismo que este lado y este otro lado me
da lo mismo que este otro lado de acá
pero ninguno es congruente con el más
grande por la diferencia en el tamaño de
sus lados por lo tanto no podemos tener
un postulado de ángulo ángulo ángulo
qué tal nos serviría un postulado de
lado ángulo lado
comencemos con un triángulo vamos a
dibujar los lados de este triángulo de
diferente color cada uno
voy a dibujar
así de color azul
otro lado de color
rosa y otro lado de color
y digamos como siempre que tengo otro
triángulo que tiene este lado azul igual
va a medir lo mismo
en este lado azul
con este lado azul van a medir lo mismo
tiene un ángulo congruente con el de
este otro lado entonces este ángulo de
acá también lo va a tener este extremo
del lado azul
este otro lado que comparte con el
ángulo también va a ser igual al lado
del primer triángulo entonces este lado
tiene la misma longitud que este otro
lado y como solo sabemos que dos de los
lados correspondientes son iguales y que
el ángulo intermedio también es igual
pues podemos hacer cualquier cosa cuando
este último lado el lado que dibujamos
en morado podría yo dibujar este lado
por acá por ejemplo
para formar el triángulo lo que tenemos
que hacer es conectar este lado con este
otro extremo del lado azul
y nos queda pues un triángulo congruente
con este primer triángulo finalmente
este lado va a ser igual a este lado de
acá así pues para dos triángulos que
tienen dos lados correspondientes
congruentes y el ángulo intermedio en
ellos también es congruente en este
ejemplo tenemos nuestro lado azul que
fue igual en ambos triángulos
nuestro ángulo que lo dibujé en naranja
intermedio nuestro ángulo
en nuestro lado en rosa que también es
igual entre ambos aquí y acá
esto nos implica que vamos a tener
triángulos congruentes entonces no se
implica congruencia congruencia
así que esto lo agregamos junto con
nuestra herramienta del lado lado lado
lado ángulo lado también nos sirve para
probar congruencia
vamos a tratar de analizar todas las
posibles combinaciones de estos lados y
ángulos para encontrar herramientas que
nos ayuden a encontrar la congruencia
me serviría
ángulo lado ángulo
dibujemos otro triángulo ahora voy a
comenzar con un lado del triángulo en
verde
al lado del triángulo en verde
otro lado en azul
el tercer lado en rosa
aquí está
y tenemos un ángulo aquí arriba que voy
a dibujar en naranja
y otro ángulo aquí abajo que voy a
dibujar en
un tono morado si yo dibujara otro
triángulo que tuviera un lado que me dé
lo mismo que este lado verde voy a
dibujar otro triángulo sé que tiene este
mismo lado de acá la longitud de este
lado y este lado son iguales y sé que
además tiene un ángulo en este extremo
que es igual al ángulo naranja de aquí y
tiene otro ángulo aquí abajo que es el
mismo ángulo que el que tenemos en este
primer triángulo
este triángulo este segundo triángulo
será concurrente necesariamente vamos a
razonar lo un poco estas no son pruebas
formales solo tratamos de encontrar
postulados razonables que podamos tener
en nuestra caja de herramientas para
poder probar otras cosas así que en este
ejemplo tenemos nuestro ángulo que es
nuestro primer ángulo es moradito
ángulo
nuestro lado que es el lado verde el que
tenemos en común lado
y nuestro otro ángulo que lo tenemos en
naranja aquí coincide
sin importar o restringir los lados que
faltan del triángulo excepto que cumplan
con esta longitud de ángulos vamos a
dibujar los otros lados el otro lado que
dibuje en este lado es el rosa vamos a
tomarlo acaba con cumplir con el ángulo
la abertura pero puede tener una
longitud muy diferente
otra es lo mismo este lado de aquí abajo
el azul debe de cumplir con la longitud
de este ángulo pero puede tener
cualquier longitud puedo dibujarlo si se
me ocurre así pero para formar un
triángulo sólo puedo tener estos dos
extremos conectados así que este
triángulo que queda sin importar la
longitud porque finalmente al unirse los
extremos la longitud va a quedar fija y
me va a forzar a tener un triángulo
congruente con este primer triángulo así
que mi enunciado de ángulo lado ángulo
este también me implica congruencia si
se cumple con esto entonces ambos
triángulos serán congruentes
otra herramienta más a nuestra caja
ya tenemos otra combinación más ahora va
a ser ángulo ángulo lado quizás si
ustedes tuvieran que memorizar esto para
un examen pues podrían recordar lado
lado lado pues tiene cierta lógica
evidente pero al lado ángulo lado y los
demás quizá no tanto yo no soy
entusiasta de la memorización aunque
quizás sirva para cuando tenemos presión
de tiempo pero es mejor razonar para
inferir y ver si estas opciones nos
sirven o no es mejor tratar de encontrar
el sentido lógico para recordar nuestros
postulados de congruencia
así pues probemos ángulo ángulo lado
ángulo ángulo lado dibujemos nuestro
triángulo
ahora vamos a dibujar el triángulo con
un lado de esta forma
el lado es en azul es este lado el que
voy a tener aquí de una vez lo pongo en
color
va a tener dos ángulos permiten dibujar
estos otros lados
voy a dibujar otro lado aquí en morado
de este triángulo así
y otro lado que lo voy a dibujar en
verde
que va a estar así
los dibujos porque me interesa marcar
los ángulos el ángulo que está aquí
junto al lado azul este ángulo lo voy a
poner en rosa
y este otro ángulo que voy a poner en un
azul más oscuro
este ángulo de acá es este otro ángulo
que estoy marcando entonces es ángulo
ángulo lado lo dibujo acá este lado no
me están restringiendo la longitud de
este otro lado simplemente que cumpla
con este ángulo y finalmente la otra
condición es tener otro ángulo igual a
éste lo puedo tener a lo mejor aquí
y se arme así la línea por ejemplo o
puedo tener este ángulo más arriba lo
puedo tener acá siempre y cuando lo que
nos piden es que se cumpla
que este tamaño del ángulo la medida del
ángulo sea la misma
pero si queremos formar un triángulo
realmente solo hay una manera de hacer
tenemos que unir los extremos tenemos
que unir este extremo con este otro con
la longitud o la medida más bien de este
ángulo de aquí
si estos dos se cumplen pues entonces
por lo que estamos viendo nos va a
generar congruencia nos implica que
estos dos triángulos serán congruentes
así que esto ángulo ángulo lado también
nos va a implicar congruencia
congruencia
también lo agregamos a nuestra caja de
herramientas hagamos un análisis más
para contemplar todas las situaciones
ahora vamos a ver la opción de lado lado
ángulo
nuevamente dibujamos un triángulo con
lados en colores diferentes
voy a dibujar este azul el otro lado va
a ser
naranja
otro lado vamos a ponerlo en un tono
morado
qué pasa si sabemos que existe otro
triángulo que tiene dos lados iguales a
este y un ángulo igual tenemos otro
triángulo que tiene un lado
igual a este
este
otro lado que es igual también pero aquí
no estamos restringidos por el ángulo
que puede haber entre estos dos lados
incluso puedo dibujar el lado este
morado más junto con un ángulo más
pequeño que en el original aunque la
longitud de estos lados sea la misma y
finalmente nos piden que el ángulo que
esté en este extremo este ángulo sea el
mismo que esté acá a primera vista
pareciera que podemos dibujar un
triángulo que no es congruente en este
ejemplo hice este ángulo entre los lados
azul y morado más pequeño en el segundo
triángulo que en el primero
y estoy conservando este otro ángulo
original como en el primer triángulo lo
que me va a causar que cuando dibuje
este lado de acá sea un lado mucho más
pequeño que en el triángulo original así
que en este enunciado donde tenemos un
lado igual o otro lado igual
y un ángulo igual esto no necesariamente
no necesariamente
necesariamente
es congruente no necesariamente es
congruente
y tampoco similar porque aquí no es como
en el primer ejemplo de ángulo ángulo
ángulo donde no tenemos congruencia pero
si una similitud los ángulos internos si
eran los mismos y coincidían aunque en
el tamaño no aquí puede que no coincida
en mi los ángulos ni los tamaños de
todos los lados